1. HAARP
Deep in the wilds of Alaska is a secretive
military research programme called HAARP,
which stands for High Frequency Active Auroral
Research Program. The facility consists of
an antenna array made up of 360 transmitters.
This giant array shoots high-power radio frequency
beams into the atmosphere, or "Ionosphere".
Some speculate HAARP is capable of emitting
a signal that has billions of watts in power.
HAARP can literally move the atmosphere, and
create holes in it, miles across. HAARP has
the power to modify the weather. Many believe
HAARP is to blame for a range of natural disasters
around the world, including floods, droughts,
hurricanes, thunderstorms and earthquakes
and it can create earthquakes at any point
on the earth by manipulating the magnetosphere.
Conspiracists believe HAARP is to blame for
the recent disasters in Haiti and Japan.
Some even believe that HAARP has developed
the ability to mind control entire populations
of people by emitting extremely low frequency
waves, adjusting their mental state.
2. Lizards
The world is run by lizards.
English author and ex-BBC reporter David Icke
wrote a series of books detailing how the
world's most powerful individuals are actually
shape-shifting reptilians. Belonging to an
ancient race of omnipotent lizard-people.
According to Icke's conspiracy, George Bush
and even the entire british royal family are
actually "reptilian" lizard people.
This is widely regarded as one of the least
believable conspiracy theories, yet 12.5 million
Americans genuinely believe the world is run
by lizard people.
3. New World Order (Illuminati)
The New World Order.
A staggering 28 percent of Americans believe
in some kind of new world order, where the
world will be ruled by a single global government
following a mass genocide. This supposed new
government is currently being built behind
the scenes by a group of secretive power elite
individuals and has been for centuries.
The most well known new world order conspiracy
is the Illuminati. The Illuminati is an ancient
group of omnipotent elites who control every
aspect of global affairs from behind the scenes,
such as government, religion and culture.
Supposed members of the Illuminati include:
Barack Obama
the Pope
Queen Elizabeth II
George W. Bush
Jay-Z
Bob Dylan
Beyoncé
Lady Gaga
and Jim Carrey
But this is just a small selection of the
hundreds of important figures who are supposed
members of this secret society. But wait,
there's more... the Illuminati is made up
of devil worshipping antichrists, yeah. When
you join the Illuminati you have to sell your
soul to the devil, if you try and leave the
illuminati you are assassinated, hence Michael
Jackson and many other mysterious deaths.
4. Denver Airport
Denver International Airport is supposedly
home to the world's largest underground bunker
or city situated right underneath the airport.
The bunker is said to house the world's most
important figures, A.K.A, the illuminati and
co., in the event of a global disaster such
as a nuclear war. Denver used to have a perfectly
adequate airport located only 6 miles from
Denver that everyone was extremely content
with. But a new airport was built in 1995
for no apparent reason, there was absolutely
nothing wrong with the previous airport. The
new airport covers 53 square miles which is
twice the size of Manhattan! The airport was
commissioned at the cost of 1.7 billion. It
was finished 2 years late and 3.1 billion
dollars over budget. The airport was privately
funded but nobody knows by who. There's a
very creepy stone in the airport which reads
funded by "The New World Airport Commission".
Guess what, The New World Airport Commission,
doesn't exist!
There are creepy murals all over the airport
depicting scenes of mass destruction, murder
and general bad times. This one in particular
shows a shadowy figure wielding a scimitar
and AK-47, stabbing a dove to death, which
is the symbol for piece... nice. He is emanating
a wave of grey smoke killing everything and
everyone in its path. That is one seriously
messed up painting. The airport is also filled
with disturbing decor, such as a gargoyle
coming out of a suitcase, erm yeah, because
nothing says "we'll look after your baggage"
than this ugly thing. If all that's not enough
to welcome you home, how about a
satanic red-eyed horse at the entrance. The
sculpture's artist Luis Jiménez actually
died whilst creating it, when it's head fell
on him.
We know there is some sort of large underground
structure beneath the airport because five
buildings were ordered to be buried underneath
the airport during it's construction. But
nobody knows how deep the rabbit hole actually
goes.
In 2011 when a comet known as Elenin narrowly
missed colliding with earth president Obama
was conveniently ushered to Denver in time
to be sheltered, from what would have been
an apocalyptic event, if it had hit. If that
doesn't scream suspicion I don't know what
does.
5. Hidden Oil Reserves
Hidden Oil Reserves.
Many believe there are huge oil and gas reserves
around the world, kept secret by the US government
and certain nefarious individuals. The media
keep telling us we are running out of oil
to create false scarcity and keep fuel prices
high, whereas we actually have access to oil
in abundance. Maybe they're saving it all
up for the New World Order.
6. Chemtrails
15.6 million americans believe in a conspiracy
called "chemtrails", short for chemical trails.
They believe the pretty white streaks left
strewn across the sky when an aeroplane passes
overhead actually contain copious amounts
of chemicals. Conspiracists believe these
chemicals, which of course are put there by
the government, have the potential to be used
for all kinds of nefarious deeds, from spreading
diseases all the way to mind control and Geoengineering.
7. Aids is Man Made, created in lab
Aids Was Created by the CIA.
Ever since 1981 when the media reported the
first AIDs pandemic, many believe the disease
was created in a lab by the CIA to wipe out
homosexuals and African Americans, charming.
Conspiracists believe that the disease was
deliberately injected into homosexuals during
the hepatitis-B experiments in San Francisco,
Los Angeles and New York during 1978.
Please note this video should not be taken
seriously, it is purely for entertainment
purposes and I am not endorsing any of the
aforementioned conspiracy theories.